du faau pour le groupe
UMP merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresser à
monsieur le ministre délégué aux anciens
combattants et sur le sujet qui nous
intéresse et en préambule je
souhaiterais que nous évitions les
polémiques et que les réponses qui me
seront apportées sortent du sanspiternel
refrain quand vous étiez au
gouvernement je souhaite également
associer à ma
question Monsieur Marcel pierre clche
président du groupe des sénateurs
anciens
combattants alors monsieur le ministre
le 24 septembre vous avez publié un
décret
amputant de 20% la rente mutualiste du
combattant je rappelle qu'elle a été
créée en 1923 s'il est impératif de
réduire la dépenses
publiqu nous considérons que cela ne
peut se faire sur le dos de ceux qui ont
combattu pour la liberté et pour les
valeurs de la
France pour les anciens combattants et
pour les soldats engagés aujourd'hui en
OPEX qui sont les les anciens
combattants de demain la rente
mutualiste est plus qu'un simple droit
que l'on ne peut ajuster au gré des
impératifs budgétaires c'est en effet un
droit
imprescriptible une reconnaissance de la
Nation toute entière pour leur
engagement et leur sacrifice sous le
drapau français alors monsieur le
ministre nous savons que vous avez
engagé des négociations avec Bery et les
principaux organismes gestionnaires tels
que la cara
ou France
Mutualiste vous avez également annoncé à
l'Assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière la création d'un comité de
suivi qui se réunirait annuellement afin
d'examiner les projections
démographiques et l'évolution des
dépenses liées à l'abondement de l'État
afin de rétablir éventuellement le taux
normal de la
majoration alors vous avez surtout
annoncé que cette mesure serait
transitoire nous voudrions bien le
croire mais nous ne sommes jamais trop
prudents et nous refons nous refusons
solennellement que ce futur Comité soit
un palliatif à une réduction du taux de
majoration de la RMC qui ferait en
quelque sorte
jurisprudence enfin et surtout raboter
le taux de majoration de la RMC c'est
s'attaquer au principe fondateur de
notre défense nationale c'est s'attaquer
au principe de l'égal
entre les générations du feu et ça c'est
inacceptable pour toute la communauté de
la défense alors monsieur le ministre à
l'heure bon nombre de nos anciens
combattants vivent en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté à l'heure où les futurs
anciens combattants sont rentrés
d'Afghanistan et se battent au Mali
pourriz-vous nous dire aujourd'hui d'une
manière précise combien de temps va
durer cette mesure transitoire
merci Madame
belcass ministre de droits des femmes
porte-parole du gouvernement
oui monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur du faau je n'ai aucune
intention de polémiquer avec vous sur ce
sujet important mais bien au contraire
de vous répondre avec précision et
peut-être avec un peu de pédagogie pour
que vous voyez plus clair sur les
intentions qui sont celles du ministre
en charge des anciens combattants retenu
par ailleurs et qui m'a chargé de vous
répondre comme vous le savez le ministre
Kader Harif c'est est entretenu avec les
acteurs du système mutualiste un
dialogue enrichi s'en étant suivi qui a
permis de dessiner des pistes pour
sécuriser les dispositifs fiscaux dont
bénéficient les anciens combattants et
de stabiliser en même temps la dépense
budgétaire afférente à ce système qu'en
est-il ressorti une baisse c'est vrai
mais très modeste de l'abondement de
l'État qui ne porte que sur la partie
spécifique et non pas sur la partie
légale de ces dispositifs mutualistes et
qui qui a permis plusieurs choses
d'abord de sécuriser la rente mutualiste
comme un dispositif qui relève du droit
à réparation ensuite de préserver la
double exonération fiscale à l'entrée et
à la sortie des rentes qui est le
principal avantage des rentes mutualiste
de maintenir ensuite à 125 points PMI le
plafond de ces rentes de maintenir à
niveau constant le coût budgétaire de la
rente mutualiste à hauteur aujourd'hui
de 255 millions d'euros et enfin et je
crois que c'est un point que vous savez
important d'éviter toute remise en cause
de la demi-part fiscale pour les veuves
d'anciens combattants voilà ce à quoi a
abouti cette concertation que deux
mutuelles importantes qui représentent
aujourd'hui environ 60 % des
bénéficiaires ont salué dans un
communiqué publié le 10 octobre dernier
disant à la fois leur satisfaction à
l'égard de la concertation qui a été
conduite par le ministre en charge des
anciens combattants mais aussi leur
accord avec la solution qui a été
élaborée en toute
transparence par ailleurs le ministre
ministre délégué aux anciens combattants
a souligné qu'une commission de suivi
serait mise en place vous l'évoquiez le
but de cette commission de suivi c'est
de surveiller précisément l'impact de
cette mesure sur les bénéficiaires de la
rente et donc une évaluation progressive
sera menée plus généralement pour
élargir le propos monsieur le sénateur
je veux souligner que dans un contexte
financier que nous savons tous difficile
tout a été fait pour préserver le budget
des anciens combattants il est à la
baisse c'est vrai 2,7 % mais cette
baisse est inférieure de moitié à celle
que la précédente majorité à laquelle
vous appartenez lui avait imposé entre
2011 et 2012 5,4 % de baisse à
l'époque cette préservation des moyens
de ce budget a permis quoi a permis de
tenir des promesses que vous-même aviez
pris il y a de nombreuses années déjà
sans jamais les tenir je pense à trois
choses en particulier l'extension du
droit à la carte du combattant aux
personnes qui ont participé aux
opérations militaires en Afrique du Nord
l'accroissement de 6 % de l'aide sociale
de l'Office national des anciens
combattants et enfin la meilleure prise
en charge des Invalides mutilés grâce au
financement de prothèse nouvelle
génération je crois qu'on peut tous les
saluer ici